nel 1576
il greco arriva a roma tre anni prima
aveva lasciato la sua città di origine a
heraklion creta per venezia aveva 26
anni in quel momento e faceva quello che
fanno i giovani da sempre cioè si
spostano dal sud al nord nei tempi di el
greco il nord partiva da dove parte
ancora oggi da roma la città dell'eterno
contrasto la città di frontiera dove il
sud inteso qui come un rapporto
rilassato con la vita incontra il
proprio nord cioè regole che chiedono
dalla vita che rispetta lo sviluppo e il
progresso le regole di quel tempo erano
consolidate cioè stampate e diffuse poi
da venezia dove il greco andrà con 417
stampatori già dal 1500 venezia che
aveva perso già da tempo il suo
superpotere mondiale economico e anche
politico un po come l'america l'ha perso
un po di anni fa era però rimasta
venezia in quel momento come l'america
lo è oggi il centro della cultura cioè
la capitale della stampa controllo
sull'informazione e dominio su quei
protocolli che possono essere fissati
sulla carta è quel che dopotutto
definisce molto più che la nostra
posizione geografica
chi è al nord o chi rimane al sud
a venezia il greco aveva trovato una
città molto simile di quelle che
troverebbe oggi un artista giovane che
arriva a new york cioè le regole del
gioco erano ormai stabilite le idee e
stili ei gesti erano uniformi e si erano
messe tutte a servire il potere senza
che le autorità neanche si occupassero
appiattimento delle differenze
era la prima regola per entrare in un
pensiero non come ad oggi e il greco
infatti abbandona il suo stile bizantino
e impara di usare le nuove tecnologie
che non sono altre che olio sulla tela
il new media del momento era inventato
in germania
di recente olio stella è a venezia lo
stavano producendo nei studio di tiziano
di tintoretto e veronese e il greco
andrà a lavorare infatti allo studio di
tiziano e prenderà da lui la sua
iconografia critica e anche quella
speziale materia e che tintoretto mette
nelle pitture che che tiziano mette
nelle pitture da tintoretto invece
prenderà le sue composizioni e l'uso
copy pays delle figure umane e o da
veronese prenderà quel suo senso di
colore e di atmosfera e poi più tardi
andando verso roma si fermerà in toscana
e da parmigianino prenderà la idea della
distorsione questo qui una cosa
importante perché la distorsione e
l'uomo proprio dal suo inizio
sono della cena ti dà sempre perché il
problema dell'uomo civilizzato
l'uomo che usa il suo cervello è un
problema di distorsione nel senso
corporeo
cioè come fissare la memoria la pittura
è un sistema che permette proprio che la
memoria viene fissata cioè viene
registrata è poi accesa dai nostri
cervelli tramite l'occhio a volontà in
questo senso la pittura non è altro che
un computer cioè fa i calcoli ora olio
sulla tela e tecnologia molto più
avanzata che computer digitali per che
raccolgono la memoria in strati certi
strati sono la pero sono invisibili
il nostro occhio non li legge però il
nostro cervello li calcola in questa
maniera
olio su tela fa qualcosa di molto molto
strano anche per il fatto che poi il
colore dell'olio non si asciuga per i
prossimi 80 anni e poi cambiano insieme
con il tempo nel quale la pittura è
presente cioè la pittura funziona certe
pitture se sono fatte in una maniera da
grande maestro funzionano o magari
funzionano non si sa come dei quanto un
computer si fanno cioè i calcoli non
solo in questo universo qui
nell'universo che uno fa la pittura ma
negli universi paralleli nei molti versi
dei quali parla la fisica quantistica il
tempo alla fine è l'artista che fa il
quadro ora dei queste cose dei quando un
computer non si sa molto però secondo un
grande scienziato di oggi david dott
magari sono capaci a diventare macchine
di tempo nel senso possono registrare il
mondo e poi in un futuro
però simularlo cioè possono simulare il
passato se questo è vero e il greco come
tutti gli artisti lo sapeva e chi anche
intuiva in quel momento storico era il
vaticano un'organizzazione una delle
prime organizzazioni tipicamente nord
con un progetto duraturo e molto molto
interessato per soluzioni che corse che
avrebbero confermato la sua rilevanza
come passato autorizzato cioè che la sua
storia e le storie che il vaticano
portava nel mondo il messaggio della
chiesa cattolica
rimarrebbero nel futuro non solamente in
questo universo qui ma la più lunga
serie di universi paralleli perché ci
sono stati universi dove il vaticano non
ha neanche mai esistito incluso il suo
gesù e vede naturalmente la una
opportunità
allora come fa oggi la nostra società
dello spettacolo e in contrario con la
chiesa bizantina da dove veniva il greco
invece di far fuori suoi nemici li
abbraccia i suoi nemici naturali cioè
gli intellettuali e gli artisti non
credenti e li lascia liberi a fare tutto
quello che vogliono
perché dopo tutto sapeva il vaticano
come sa oggi lo spettacolo che le forme
le immagini non hanno nessuna importanza
dopo tutto quello che conta è la cuba
non hanno importanza dal punto di vista
di controllo nord quello che conta da
quel punto di vista su come controllare
il mondo e accumulare sopra le immagini
attorno le immagini sacralità e fama in
modo che crei una distanza
è la distanza dopotutto distanza da chi
non fa immagini dal popolo dalle
moltitudini e la distanza alla fine è
quello che protegge il potere e vaticano
ha sempre manipolato le distanze con le
sue crociate ha cancellato le distanze
vere cominciando così una grande
industria del nord
l'industria del turismo d'altra parte
affidandosi il suo muro a certi artisti
che poi quel muro stesso avrebbe reso
famosi ha creato distanza proprio
laddove distanza non dovrebbe esistere
cioè sull'arte ha dato inizio così
vaticano a una seconda industria che
senza di quella industria non sarebbe
stato possibile
l'impero nord totale del quale tutti noi
siamo oggetti soggetti oggi cioè
l'industria dello spettacolo e ora qui
torniamo per un attimo lasciamo il greco
torniamo nel nostro presente e
guardiamolo che cos'è il nostro presente
è il momento del turismo spettacolo
tecnologia ma cosa sono queste cose è un
turismo che si appropria di tutto perché
si sente autorizzato è uno spettacolo
che copre tutto è una tecnologia che in
differenza di quel che ci vogliono far
credere
esiste poco e invece di potenziare la
nostra capacità di collegamento col
mondo se la toglie
dopo tutto quel che oggi chiamiamo
computer e internet non sono altro che
schermi schermi patetici che noi abbiamo
imparato a usare e che sempre di più
dimentichiamo quelli schermi potenti
come la pittura come l'agricoltura come
molte altre cose
e sempre di più noi ci accontentiamo di
depositare il nostro sapere le nostre
informazioni il nostro database fuori
del mondo fuori scusa fuori di noi
stessi fuori dei nostri corpi in dischi
di memoria in clouds che poi a noi non
appartengono
allora siamo arrivati così in una
versione del mondo con primitivi con dei
selvaggi i primitivi e selvaggi era un
sogno delle società borghese del secolo
scorso rimasto un po da noi non sono mai
esistiti non ci sono mai esistiti
primitivi e selvaggi nel mondo oggi si
siamo noi la gente di roma
scusi di new york di londra e di milano
l'azienda del computer
il popolo della informazione cosiddetta
in questo nord allora disperante
e rimasta invece una speranza
immaginiamolo come una specie di
triangolo un triangolino che è la sua
apice è sempre a roma e guarda verso
africa il nord attorno diventa una
specie di pac man e lo sta mangiando
minuti sono finiti però in stile medio
sud a dro un pò avanti
questa è l'idea veloce del medio sud
cioè che fai parte di un certo mondo fai
parte di una terra però non rispetti
esattamente le regole va un pochino più
avanti allora quel tempo di el greco
questa bocca era rivolta verso la spagna
dove infatti lui poi andrà a fare le sue
pitture magnifiche dando questa specie
di espressione raccogliendo tutte le
informazioni dal nord però lasciandosi
su una spesa di distorsione molto più
totale che brucia i corpi brucia i
paesaggi 10 di spenderla per spettiva e
crea quella cosa che sappiamo come il
greco invece nei nostri tempi dobbiamo
fare una cosa molto simile se vogliamo
un po uscire da questo enorme putnam che
adesso infatti è rivolto su tutto il
mondo e che gira e freddi come dice
questa conferenza qui è un 3d e una
piramide è un cono medio sud è una
specie di luce che ricordatevi visto che
siamo qui a roma ha la sua capitale
la sua frontiera da sempre oggi qui a
roma